now while world leaders were gathered in
New York Moscow has announced plans to
hold referendums on formally annexing
parts of Ukraine occupied by its forces
and their separatist allies Ukraine's
President volodimir zielinski's Office
says any such move would destroy the
remaining chances for peace talks the
planned referendums announced today come
after Ukrainian forces made sweeping
gains on the battlefield in the east of
the country driving back Russian troops
Ukrainian presidential spokesman Andre
yermak says Russia is showing signs of
desperation writing this on his telegram
Channel naive blackmail with threats and
horror stories of quote referendums and
quote mobilizations from those who know
how to fight only with children and
peaceful people this is what the fear of
defeat looks like the enemy is afraid
and for more on this I'm now joined by
Dr Jade McGlynn she is a senior
researcher at the Monterey initiative in
Russian studies and author of the
upcoming book titled Russia's War she
joins us from Oxford in England Dr
McGlynn good to have you on the day
Ukraine says Russia is sensing defeat is
that really what's happening
I think so yes
um the counter-offensive clearly uh took
the Russians by surprise and their
inability either their failure of
intelligence in not expecting it or
their total inability to move enough
troops around or indeed to have enough
reserves to fight back in any way
effectively in the counter-offensive in
harkive region
suggests an army that is clearly not
performing up to the propaganda
propagandistic bombast with which it's
often announced in Russian
what would an annexation mean for the
situation on the ground for the people
who could go from living in
russian-controlled territory to
territory annexed by Russia
this is very worrying because some of
the territories for example zaparitia
and Herson that are suggesting to the
annexed are not entirely controlled by
Russia in fact even Donetsk and I think
even now luhanski aren't entirely
controlled by Russia but with zacharesia
for example the collaborationist
authorities there have said that the
whole of zaprasia will hopefully join
Russia um after these kind of sham
referendum but they don't even control
the main city of the Region's Apparition
itself so then it leads us into some
interesting questions where will the
Russians think that the ukrainians are
occupying Russian land it's just it's
just totally bizarre and of course the
worrying thing is that it could be used
as a way of
um as an excuse for even more nuclear
blackmail IE threats of nuclear attacks
because of course if Russia sees that
territory as as Russia then any attack
on that territory could be used to
justify a nuclear strike or at least the
threat of one yeah and I want to read
something to you that um a former
president Dimitri Medvedev wrote on
telegram today he said an encroachment
on the territory of Russia is a crime
that warrant any means of self-defense
so do you believe this move uh to
illegitimately swallow up Ukrainian
territory could lead to an even greater
escalation of the war not not only in
Zappa regia and around the nuclear plant
but in general where we see Ukrainian
troops trying to regain control of their
territories and Russia treating it as an
incursion into into Russian territory
I think um first of all of course to
mention my videos
um transformation from sort of geeky
liberal technocrats sort of 12 years ago
into sort of terrifying warmonger is
it's been quite the scene to behold but
I would also recall that he said a
similar thing about attacks on Crimea on
his telegram Channel and then when the
ukrainians did attack Crimea he deleted
that telegram post so you know a similar
way there was quite a lot of talk about
what Russia would do if Sweden and
Finland joined NATO and that didn't
really come to pass so I definitely
think since
because of the gravity and the horror of
what we are talking about in terms of a
nuclear strike of course we must tread
very carefully and we must
um
cleaning you'll have to be very sensible
because even if there's a one percent
risk such as such as the horror that
that it's worth being very very cautious
indeed however I don't think we should
just sort of
um bend and buckle um to everything the
Russians say the Russians are clearly
not doing very well in the war at the
moment
um clearly it does look like a tide has
turned the Ukrainian Army is receiving
you know incredibly um technologically
Superior Weaponry to that which uh
Russia has the Russian army has the
Russian army is lacking in morale the
Russian armies is lacking in its ability
to to get enough men
and so it's kind of natural that they
would of course have have recourse or
decide to to call upon their their
nuclear Supremacy which is something you
know that they mentioned quite a lot
even before long before the war there
was quite a lot of references because
you know nuclear weapons is one of the
few areas where Russia genuinely is a
superpower and it can really back it up
with the hard figures
the Russian Parliament voted today to
toughen the punishment for a desertion
and insubordination in times of military
mobilization how big of a problem does
that seem to be among Russian troops
I think I think it is a problem but I I
personally have interpreted these laws
more about the future and more about the
possibility of either that either
dangling the possibility of mobilization
or because they are preparing for
mobilization
um and of course it's always a Fool's
game to make predictions especially in
this war when people have when everybody
has you know been wrong at one point or
another
um but it does look like we have signs
that if not a full mobilization then
perhaps a partial mobilization may be on
its way and in that case of course these
laws would make it very hard for people
um or to surrender to to go over to the
Ukrainian side or to join any of the
alleged
um sort of Russian pro-ukrainian
brigades that are that are now fighting
in Ukraine as well some analysts believe
that that these referendums that are now
on the table are
um a way of trying to force Ukraine to
to the negotiating table do you think
that would work
no mainly because of the I mean it's
that it's the feature that gets
forgotten I think sometimes for
everybody which is the ukrainians
um even if um valodian zelensky wanted
to go to the negotiation tables and I
have to say there's not much sign of
that either but even if he did Ukraine I
mean sort of what this is all about
Ukraine is a democracy and I think it's
93 of ukrainians are against making any
concessions even in Crimea
um in order to to secure peace and I
think it would be very hard to convince
the ukrainians as well that such a a
piece and that you almost want to put in
in scare quotes but that's such a piece
would be enduring and that would be a
piece for them or would it just be a
piece you know for us in the rest of
Europe and and for the Russians sure so
it's it's not going well for Putin is it
and descent among Civil Society is
growing just last week local politicians
asked Putin in an open letter to resign
for the good of the country what's the
extent of frustration with Vladimir
Putin
that's of course quite difficult to
judge and I wouldn't overstate that I
wouldn't overstate the level of
frustrational protest I mean the that
particular process as well was phrased
in such a way where of course it was
quite obvious to which Putin they were
referring but there was an element of
deniability plausible deniability to it
um and I think that's kind of what
allowed it to happen was there was a
sort of Dublin Tundra going on there
um it more generally in Civil Society a
lot of I mean there are difficulties
with trusting polls
um at the moment but what I would say is
actually a lot of the findings at the
moment are quite ambiguous and they
suggest a sort of sense of a lot of
Russians are just tuning off from the
war
um even we can see this quite literally
in terms of the television figures as
well people have just stopped watching
the the sort of the more propagandistic
and bombastic shows and there's a
genuine feeling of kind of well not that
they would agree to anything that's
certainly not the way to read it but
more of a or just you said you're going
to do it so just get on with it and I
think a general kind of apathy and not
wanting to take responsibility for for
what's happening but I'd I'd be I would
certainly caution against any
interpretation that this is sort of
Putin and the elites war and and the
Russian people you know it's kind of
being forced on the Russian people I
don't think that that would be a correct
interpretation okay you are writing a
book called Russia's War without any
spoilers how do you see it ending
the war or the book well I think that
kind of goes in unison doesn't it both
if you want
it does a bit actually
um you know first of all I had I just
submitted the manuscript uh last week
um but first of all I had a very
depressing conclusion and it was I just
felt like it wasn't the right conclusion
um and in the end I changed it and
ultimately I do think that this war will
end in in defeat for Russia in in some
form
and I think that that defeat will lead
very quickly to some sort of
um to some sort of collapse now when
this will happen that I do not know
um but I think things will go quite
quickly but the way
um but I do think that I do think that
this is Russia's War I think that this
war resonates with people and I think
that that broadly people if they don't
full-on support it then they acquiesce
to it they agreed to it they accept it
without condemning it however I also
think that Russia isn't doomed to be
this way I think that there could be you
know there could be a different Russia
countries change and I hope that in the
future we see a Russia that that is able
to live at peace with itself and with
its neighbors um but I don't really see
the War ending until
until that change until the Russians are
ready to make that change and I think
there needs to be something organic and
something that comes from from Russia
itself Dr Jade McGlynn of the Monterey
initiative in Russian studies thank you
so much for all that
thank you